joining us here on the rich isaac joe
big week for this man uh wipeout returns
to tbs at nine eastern tonight starting
on thursday on hbo max the peacemaker
premieres uh and we've always enjoyed
his character uh of peacemaker from the
suicide squad movie of james gunn's 2021
movie
and and of course he's just one of the
most popular guys around he's known as
the voice of ferdinand at my house i'm
going to end this long introduction
because we only have a limited amount of
time with john cena how you doing john
rich eisen you promotional juggernaut
thank you very much for the introduction
i appreciate it you know what uh that
may be the nicest thing anybody's ever
called me john i'll be very honest with
you promotional juggernaut that's right
i like setting your expectations low sir
however
i am good what a big week this is in the
life of john cena very exciting there's
a you know a lot of buzz around the show
um early reviews have been very strong
audience engagement is good i am in new
york right now i know you can't see me
and that's kind of like in a meta thing
that's kind of my existence anyway yes
the full peacemaker costume as we are uh
running through the final moments to get
people to watch this thing on hbo so i'm
just need to ask you this uh does this
does this mean that you still have
television uh because again you're not
on camera here you still have television
appearances for the rest of the day or
you're you're just so committed to the
role that you're in character or
off-camera right now i honestly think a
safe answer there is both okay uh and
i'm okay with saying that both okay you
know what uh that's cause you're a
professional you're a lead pipe wielding
professional i think that's what we
would like i'm someone who got lucky to
slip into the professional ranks and i
really shouldn't be here anyway
i'm gonna go down swinging with the
costume so now
you lost the lid to to fallon last night
is that it did okay what happened he uh
definite home field advantage that son
of a [ __ ]
i don't even own the helmet and i lost
it um
i wanted it we we play all these games
we play these stupid games
actually a really cool like football
breaking glass one but we played even
played a game called fishlap where you
just slap somebody in the face with a
fish there's no like if you get the
answer wrong you get slapped you just
slap a person in the face with a fish
yes and he called the game fish lap but
there's never any friggin stakes nothing
is ever we don't play for anything
so to make something competitively
interesting you got to have something on
the line and i foolishly
bet the helmet and i he was gonna give
me a tonight show mike and i said that
was garbage i want him to uh frost his
hair tips
because he would hate it so much you'd
have to get a really short haircut right
two for one for me
but like i said uh sucker's bet and he
knew that he actually knew what game it
was and i had no clue i went in
overconfident i blame it on the
peacemaker outfit
and i ended up losing the helmet well i
mean we have for those who don't know i
think they all do but anyway a shot of
the helmet on camera that looks
expensive john i'm not gonna lie does
that mean uh there's a garnished wage of
some sort in your next check so i was i
was under the impression that i wouldn't
be receiving any pay for playing
peacemaker in the first place i'm just
happy that i could get out on the field
so they say and do my thing
no one has ever referred to me as a
professional and i think one of those
things uh is pay so
they may put that one on my tab uh the
checks in the mail can i say that you
can hey man
if they don't get it in a few days just
wait longer you're john cena you could
say whatever you want man
you could say whatever you want and so
okay uh it you look like you have a
blast playing this role john no it's fun
it's fun and i think the fun thing about
it is the guy is so flawed he is so uh
broken and
there's something about characters
especially when you lean into what i
would call an eight-hour movie here on
hbo max is we got eight episodes of this
thing
that you see and we saw this a bit in
the suicide squad he has like a moment
he's just a real
just a real bad guy and his ethos is uh
i love peace so much i don't care who i
have to kill to get right there you get
an idea that this guy is not wired
straight
and
i think it's his journey and people like
because when we announced the show a lot
of the audience members were like why
are you giving this douche bag his own
show
he's he's the least likeable character
in the suicide squad where i was in a
bloodsport or a polkadot man a rat
catcher too
and um
i think it's that engagement of like
can this guy be better will this guy
grow
what journey am i going to go on and
what hilarity am i going to see on the
way and and man hats off to james gunn
and the crew james wrote a a beautiful
mini series and we got i'm so glad we
got
had so much fun doing it it came out
great and i i know anticipation is high
for the series and i really hope
everybody enjoys it when they can
finally see it on hbo max john cena here
on the rich eisen show and so um i'm
looking at the cast and of all the cast
members one name leaps out at me robert
patrick want to talk about a badass um
you know he's been here before we he and
i both share a
a love of the university of michigan
together you got a good robert patrick
story i mean you know mr t
robert patrick's story so the very first
film i was a part of
when i was just a a bright-eyed wwe
champion not knowing which way was up
with the film uh we did in 2004 or five
in australia called the marine and the
lead uh villain in the marine was none
other than the robert patrick's
so he kind of got to and he played one
hell of a part for us i uh i would have
had to be a whole lot better to have
sucked in that movie and he really uh
did the yeoman's work and it was great
you know all these years later you know
almost 20 years later to come back and
perform with robert again and fittingly
enough he's my dad he's auggie smith uh
i was and to have such an instrumental
role in the series it was it was awesome
to be able to come back and perform with
robert again he's one of a kind he is
one of a kind he's a total badass and
just you know i mean obviously t2 go way
back there and he must have tons of
stories and
that must be just neat stuff when the
cameras are off and you just shoot it
with him oh and and it's neat stuff when
they're on to i can't wait
he says he had the most fun uh playing
auggie smith and he's he's openly told
james gunn that and i really hope uh
you know that that he's he's really
really good at this part and it's it's
he takes some really bold brave swings
and i'm very happy that uh he brought
that sort of energy to set because i i i
would see only him doing this john cena
here on the rich eisen show i don't mean
to get too deep with you john but i'm
about to let's do it okay so you you
play uh the peacemaker right you play
peacemaker and he's a guy who says he's
about peace but clearly you know he has
conflicts right yeah and you play john
cena in wipeout where you revel in
people face planting and having all
sorts of misery
do you see a theme here john just you're
picking
picking something up here
i see a guy trying to connect the dots
contain a human being in a light where
they're one dimensional i see that
you see what i mean i mean you know
people are just absolutely crushing
themselves you're wondering if they're
really hurt you know we're hoping that
that never wonder i know they're okay
okay that's yeah okay
all right they have they have a blast on
the show we got a bunch of crazy
characters on wipeout they they know
what they're signing up for and we do a
we do a great job to give them wipeouts
rich that's what we do on wi-fi that's
wipeout that's true so if somebody just
like runs straight through it and it's
no big deal and they actually show off
some actual physical skills that then
then you don't have a show right yes and
i think that's where uh nicole and i are
the most surprised when someone actually
does well because the course the course
isn't constructed for that it's not like
an american ninja warrior thing where
you can write your own course at home in
practice yes it really and the
everything is uh based with water and
everything is heavily padded but it is
built for you to spill it is built for
you to
be a highlight uh epic fail and
people i people embrace that and and
honestly
we've had people just not run the
obstacles you can time out there's a
time limit on each obstacle and we've
had people just pass so they you know
they're brave enough to get cast they
bring this crazy personality and then
they just sit there and we've watched
them just sit there and a lot of times
it's in the finals too and we watch them
just sit there and eventually just pass
all right i got john cena here uh on the
rich eisen show so you're you're from
massachusetts john what
where's your accent did you ever have
one did you ever have i uh you know
years ago i went uh i went to boarding
school at age uh 15 16-ish
and that was kind of the beginning of
the end for the massachusetts accent now
if you get me back into the the mean
street of west newberry and uh you know
you give me one too many sam adams uh
uh
i may bring it back for a little bit but
maybe i'm saving it maybe i'm saving it
for another for another character down
the road that
mark wahlberg uh matt damon yeah john
cena brothers movie good john cena so i
mean so do you have it like seriously
can you can you bust it out can you like
give it you know what it no
uh okay there it is
it'd be wicked hard to bust it out but
like like i said i need beers
you know because again i i'm i'm from
staten island new york if you cut me off
in traffic it comes out you know yeah
with me i go back to see my family for
the holidays and it takes about three
days
but on the third day it was like i was
born and raised in east boston
i love it
i love it all right let's go back to
some more roots i've got my social media
grand maester tj jefferson here is a die
hard wrestling fan i'll give you the
floor t.j for a question to the great
john cena go for it
do what you do shower the the map of
misinformation and come up with a
question
yes first of all john i want to say
congratulations on all your success post
wrestling i mean i remember watching you
in one as the prototype doing a car
commercial for i think lebron
yes indeed yes indeed i remember
watching that and then i remember
watching you when you made your debut i
was like yeah was that the prototype
from the card commercial so
it was local access car commercials
that's where it all started for me
congratulations on everything brother
thank you so much um i just want to say
this i i know you've been busy so you're
probably not paying as much as attention
to the wwe as you you probably once did
but there's a lot of weird stuff going
on man a lot of weird releases and i
know a lot of fans are kind of like
they're curious they're worried
do you have any take on on what's going
on and you as a former top guy there
would it have bothered you to see all of
these people that you could be making
money with and having great matches with
let go
well okay um
there's there's a lot to unpack there um
when i i will say this uh when i started
in the wwe uh the wwe had just absorbed
wcw and ecw
and the raw and also uh had two
developmental territories and the
rosters were
um
abundant is is is probably a good word
so
when i started in the wwe there there
were releases twice a year
and it created stakes
for developmental talent and it created
stakes for
uh talent to try to make a name for
themselves because we we just knew we
knew that on a calendar year
shortly after wrestlemania and either
before or after the holidays there would
be cuts there always were
and that that seemed to stop
uh
man right around when we really began to
redefine ourselves with our new like our
new school i'll say like the ruthless
aggression
era style of characters me brock uh
randy dave
when we
when those guys began to anchor in and
develop the program
going forward into the next decade or
more
and we we started to expand our reach we
started having more programming
uh
the talent rosters started to get big
and then it became i think a lot of it
wwe's hiring strategy i think a lot of
it might have and this is once again i'm
not thinking for the wwe this is just me
posing a different perspective
i think a lot of it might have been a
little slightly defensive hiring because
there was a there was and still is a
giant boom right now in sports
entertainment people are absorbing this
content they're engaging uh you know
people are making a name for themselves
outside of the wwe is no longer a
one-stop shop so i think with this flux
of
passionate people who love sports
entertainment
people do get a name for themselves
outside the wwe and if if the wwe feels
maybe that they can be a fit in that
world
they're going to try to give that person
a shot
they're also really um
they're really bullish on continuing to
hire new talent so the the the nxt
performance center
is i don't want to say overwhelmed but
they're they're at max capacity so you
have all of these
performers
and a lot of them
you know aren't aren't getting a chance
to perform and i think i think that's
the real frustrating thing uh both to
the wwe and from a stance of a performer
and
unfortunately at the end of the day
it is a business
and i
i remember when i started in the wwe uh
i want i want to use the word fortunate
i was fortunate enough to be at the show
in atlanta where stone cold steve austin
was fired
and that moment right there
um
it it shot through me like a cannon
because i got the impression that if
they could fire stone cold steve austin
unless your name was vince mcmahon
everyone is replaceable
and i think a lot of the frustration
from from the audience out there
is they they view they view sports
entertainment like i do i love watching
matches i love seeing potential in human
beings i love seeing potential in
performers and i see potential in
everybody especially when people begin
to define what they would call a gimmick
or personality i love to be able to try
to run with it on conversations and see
how far we can take it
but there is only so many spots there is
only so much programming and
i understand from a business standpoint
the
the amount of releases that have had to
had to happen
if the company justifies that hey this
is the move we're making we want to
carry less talent it has it has very
little to do with
uh profit loss margin if the company
strategy is to run on a lean
roster
it doesn't it doesn't matter you run on
a lean roster if the company strategy is
to to run on a fat roster i remember
when we had
stacks of performers and the stock price
was at seven bucks
it's just the directive that the company
was given to run on a talent heavy
roster or talent lean roster
and i know um
obviously this is a touchy subject and
it's going to
elicit perspective from everyone and
everyone certainly is entitled to their
perspective i think i think the sad
thing here
is
people who
who
are have this gift
uh aren't being allowed to use it and
people you know people are out of a job
and that that is the absolute saddest
thing that people no longer can
work at a company that they called home
for a period of time
i feel for everybody who's just had to
go in that direction but
all of us myself included our journey
will
eventually have an end and when when
you're in it sometimes you don't have
that perspective but i personally
uh from from my early days in the wwe
always
had the perspective that it could be
over tomorrow for any and all of us
because if they can fire steve austin
there's no way i'm even close to his
ability and that means they can fire me
but that's just the culture i was
brought up and i was brought in i'm
brought up in bi-annual cuts
and it happened all the time and i just
think we went through
wwe went through such a long period of
not releasing anybody and now
they're kind of getting back into that
rhythm again that it is a very abrupt
shift
to somebody who's not familiar with that
and i do my heart goes out to everybody
who uh who has to get that that sad news
because it is that's a that's a that's a
tough conversation to have john cena i
really appreciate that answer and the
time and the conversation and uh we
ended up you said you were gonna get
deep you were not kidding oh you know
what i i got deep and then uh my guy tj
jefferson got deeper and uh i appreciate
you going there wherever uh we took him
and uh i guess last question uh for mike
for my children uh is there more
ferdinand anywhere oh man i hope so i
loved doing that what a beautiful carlos
beautiful i'm really glad that you say
you were known as ferdinand in my house
that's that that's true that was very
proud of them thank you absolutely
absolutely true because i also need you
to get more peyton manning in uh in in
in some you know
rich do me a favor don't let your kids
watch peacemaker just yet
[Laughter]
ferdinand's the gateway
yeah and then see if it's okay for them
it won't be okay for them but that's for
you to judge us the gateway is ferdinand
wipeout peacemaker that's the good way
is
take care of yourself john cena always
appreciate it take care so much you got
it john cena on twitter instagram check
out peacemaker on hbo max thursday and
tonight the premiere again of wipeout on
tbs
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here